you've been investing in tech companies
for about let's say 20 years and uh
about 15 of which was uh with Andreessen
Horowitz
uh what interesting Trends in Tech have
you seen over that time let's just talk
about companies and just the evolution
of the tech industry I mean the big
shift over 20 years has been that Tech
used to be a tools industry for
basically from like 1940 through to
about 2010 almost all the big successful
companies were picks and travels
companies so PC database smartphone you
know some some some tool that somebody
else would pick up and use
since 2010 most of the big wins have
been in applications so a company that
starts a comp you know it starts in an
existing industry and goes directly to
the customer in that industry and you
know the early examples there were like
uber and Lyft and Airbnb
um and then that model is kind of
elaborating out
um the AI thing is actually a reversion
on that for now because like most of the
AI business right now is actually in
Cloud provision of of AI apis for other
people to build on but but the big thing
will probably be an app yeah I think I
think most of the money I think probably
will be in whatever yeah your AI
financial advisor or your AI doctor or
your AI lawyer or you know take your
pick of whatever the domain is
um and there and what's interesting is
you know we the valley kind of does
everything we our the entrepreneurs kind
of elaborate every possible idea and so
there will be a set of companies that
like make AI something that can be
purchased and used by large law firms um
and then there will be other companies
that just go direct to Market as a as an
AI lawyer
what advice could you give for startup
founder just haven't seen so many
successful companies so many companies
that fail also what advice could you
give to a startup founder someone who
wants to build the next super successful
startup in the tech space the Googles
the apples the twitters
yeah so the great thing about the really
great Founders is they don't take any
advice so
if you find yourself listening to advice
maybe you shouldn't do it
um but that's actually just to elaborate
on that if you could also speak to Great
Founders yeah like what makes a great
founder
so what makes a great founder is super
smart
um coupled with super energetic coupled
with super courageous I think it's some
of those those three initelligence
Passion and courage the first two are
traits and the third one is a choice I
think courage is a choice well because
courage is a question of pain tolerance
right
um
so um how how many times you're willing
to get punched in the face before you
quit yeah um and
here's maybe the biggest thing people
don't understand about what it's like to
be a startup founder is it gets it gets
very romanticized right um and even when
it even when they fail it still gets
romanticized about like what a great
adventure it was but like
the reality of it is most of what
happens is people telling you no and
then they usually follow that with
you're stupid right no I will not come
to work for you um I will not leave my
cushy job at Google can work for you no
I'm not going to buy your products you
know no I'm not going to run a story
about your company no I'm not this that
the other thing
um and so a huge amount of what people
have to do is just get used to just
getting punched and and the reason
people don't understand this is because
when you're a Founder you cannot let on
that this is happening because it will
cause people to think that you're weak
and they'll lose faith in you yeah so
you have to pretend that you're having a
great time when you're dying inside
right
it's just a misery but why why do they
do it what do they do oh yeah that's the
thing it's like it is a level it's
actually one of the conclusions I think
is it I think it's actually for most of
these people on a risk adjusted basis
it's probably an irrational act they
could probably be more financially
successful on average if they just got
like a real job at a big company
um but there's you know some people just
have an irrational need to do something
new and build something for themselves
and you know some people just can't
tolerate having bosses oh here's the fun
thing is how do you reference check
founders right so you call it you know
normally you reference check your time
hiring somebody as you call the bosses
so they're in you know and you find out
if they were good employees and now
you're trying to reference check Steve
Jobs right and it's like oh God he was
terrible you know he was a terrible
employee he never did what we told him
to do yeah
so what's a good reference if you want
the previous boss to actually stay there
there they never did what you told them
to do that might be a good thing well
ideally ideally what you want is I will
go I would like to go to work for that
person
um he worked for me here and now I'd
like to work for him no unfortunately
most people can't their egos can't can't
handle that so they won't say that but
that that's the ideal what advice would
you give to those folks in the space of
intelligence passion and courage so I
think the other big thing is you see
people sometimes who say I want to start
a company and then they kind of work
through the process of coming up with an
idea and generally those don't work as
well as the case where somebody has the
idea first and then they kind of realize
that there's an opportunity to build a
company and then they just turn out to
be the right kind of person to do that
when you say idea do you mean
what long-term big Vision or do you mean
specifics of like product specific let's
say specific like specifically what yes
specifics like what is because for the
first five years you don't get to have
Vision you just got to build something
people want and you've got to figure out
a way to sell it to them right it's very
practical or you never get to Big Vision
so so the first the first part you have
an idea of a set of products or the
first product that can actually make
some money yeah like it's got a first
product's got to work by which I mean
like it has to technically work but then
it has to actually fit into the category
in the customer's mind of something that
they want and then and then by the way
the other part is they have to want to
pay for it like somebody's got to pay
the bills and so you've got to figure
out how to price it and whether you can
actually extract the money yeah so
usually it is much more predictable
success is never predictable but it's
more predictable if you start with a
great idea and then back into starting
the company
um so this is what we did you know we
mostly before we escape the Google guys
had the Google search engine working at
Stanford um right um the um uh you know
yeah there's tons of examples where they
you know uh Pierre omadir had eBay
working before he left his previous job
so I really love that idea of just
having a thing a prototype that actually
works before you even begin to remotely
scale yeah by the way it's also far
easier to raise money right like the
ideal pitch that we receive is here's
the thing that works would you like to
invest in our company or not like that's
so much easier than here's 30 slides
with a dream right
um and then we have this concept called
the dmas which are biology srinivasan
came up with um when he was with us um
so so so then there's this thing this
goes to mythology which is um you know
there's a mythology of that kind of you
know these these ideas um you know kind
of arrive like magic or people kind of
stumble into them it's like eBay with
the pest dispensers or something
um the reality usually with the big
successes is that the founder has been
chewing on the problem for five or ten
years before they start the company and
they often worked on it in school
um or they even experimented on it when
they were a kid
um and they've been kind of training up
over that period of time to be able to
do the thing so they're like a true
domain expert
and and it's it sort of sounds like Mom
and apple pie which is yeah you want to
be a domain expert what you're doing but
you would you know the mythology is so
strong of like oh I just like had this
idea in the shower and now I'm doing it
like it's generally not that no because
well maybe in the shower you had the
exact
product implementation details but yeah
usually you're going to be for like
years if not decades thinking about
like
everything around that what we call it
the idea maze because the idmas
basically is like there's all these
permutations like for any ID for any
idea there's like all these different
permutations who should the customer be
what shape forms the product have and
how should we take it to Market and all
these things
um and so um the really smart Founders
have thought through all these scenarios
by the time they go out to raise money
um and they have like detailed answers
on every one of those fronts because
they put so much thought into it
um the sort of the the sort of more
haphazard Founders haven't thought about
any of that and it's the detailed ones
who tend to do much better so how do you
know when to take a leap if you have a
cushy job or happy life
I mean the best reason is just because
you can't tolerate not doing it right
like this is the kind of thing where if
you have to be advised into doing it you
probably shouldn't do it
um and so it's probably the opposite
which is you just have such a burning
sense of this has to be done I have to
do this I have no choice what if it's
going to lead to a lot of pain it's
going to lead to a lot of pain
I think that's what if it means uh
losing sort of social relationships and
damaging your
um relationship with loved ones and all
that kind of stuff yeah look so like
it's going to put you in a social tunnel
for sure right so you're gonna like uh
you know
there's this game you can play on
Twitter which is you can do any whiff of
the idea that there's uh basically any
such thing as work-life balance and that
people should actually work hard and
everybody gets mad but like the truth is
like all the successful Founders are
working 80 hour weeks and they're
working you know they perform very very
strong social bonds with the people they
work with they tend to lose a lot of
friends on the outside or put those
friendships on ice like that's just the
nature of the of the thing
um you know for most people it's worth
the trade-off you know the advantage you
know maybe younger Founders have is
maybe they have less you know maybe
they're not you know for example if
they're not married yet or don't have
kids yet that's an easier thing to bite
off can you be an older founder yeah you
definitely can yeah um yeah many of the
most successful Founders are second
third fourth time Founders they're in
their 30s 40s 50s um the good news of
being an older founder is you know more
and you you know a lot more about what
to do which is very helpful the problem
is okay now you've got like a spouse and
a family and kids and like you've got to
go to the baseball game and like you
can't go to the base you know and so
it's it
life is full of difficult choices yes